Hey hi can you see me now oh we have
communication at lost Chris Anderson
believes drones will be a force for good
military technology journalist David
hambling has his doubts so you now got
your own drone company so what's the big
challenge now at the moment for for you
and for the drone industry generally for
moving it forward so that first phase
was sort of like the DIY phase the
second phase was the consumer phase and
we're now entering the commercial phase
where these things are now a tool that
does something useful
I enjoy the small consumer trying to get
you syste now we're increasingly hearing
reports that militias like the
Ukrainians fighting the Russians like
the Kurds fighting Isis are actually
using them for military reconnaissance
yeah are you aware of your products
venues that way and then how do you feel
about it if you told me that our drones
have been used for by terrorists I'd
feel really bad about that one of the
interesting things about drone
technology is the autonomy is moving so
quickly it's software based and so it's
very diffused and it's very accessible
that you can actually buy online for
under a thousand dollars a drone that
has more autonomy than a US Air Force
Reaper drone you go buy something online
relatively inexpensive that not only can
can take off and land on their own they
can fly point-to-point with the GPS
coordinate but some of them can track
and follow objects some of the more
state-of-the-art ones have object
avoidance so if it's about to fly into a
tree it'll move around and not hit it
that's much more sophisticated autonomy
then the military actually has in there
drones
when you look at the eye Edie it's been
a huge problem for you as troops in
Afghanistan in the last 15 years but
those are things that were there in
place we would go run into the IAD now
we're looking at world where the IEDs
come for us and that certainly is a
problem not just for troops on the
battlefield but also for homeland
defense issues a flying IEDs exactly
where we're coming to we saw this in
Japan the Prime Minister's residents had
a drone with radiological material flown
onto the residence the Japanese
officials had no response they couldn't
respond to it
imagine someone flown in a drone to the
White House with radiological material
you're jamming it you make it fall from
the sky
the radiological material disperses if
you shoot it down it fall from the sky
radiological material disperses there
are a lot of events in the world that
we've seen where bad guys are using
these in ways we've never imagined
before how do we stop these things it
may be only a matter of time before
terrorists mount an attack using
commercial drones so the armies of the
world especially the US Department of
Defense are racing to find ways to stop
drone attacks in their tracks
[Music]
you